you can get to common painful
instead they went
or
was called to white
you see that a lot from people or do you
feel that
definitely yeah I definitely feel that
way I mean a lot of people who I have
family I have friends who I know of that
there's something they really want or
something they really love but they're
just too scared to give it to go after
it because like I said the other option
is safer I think in my situation though
I don't think it was about being safe
because his pursuing acne is definitely
not a safe choice both of them personal
athlete acting it's tough for me for me
it was a decision about which one do I
just full of more which one do I just
want to put everything I have into it
but as far as your question goes yeah I
see that all the time and I feel bad for
those people I always tell them just
steal it just take one step try it see
see what you'll get from it because you
all you always look back as neckline
water what if I would have done
time why don't some
kid and the expectancy professional some
people type
but when they want pursue acting
we put a lot of pressure on that person
would you save someone's in that such
that they loving family
part of the family unit but they almost
feel excluded in Somerset
I mean up top my head I have I would
tell them you know go for it anyway I
mean it's their life I mean you want to
love your family and you know being good
relationship with have a good
relationship with them good same time
it's your life and you got to do what
makes you happy and from a personal
standpoint I did have that experience I
mean my family wanted me to be a doctor
or a lawyer accountant and they were
very anti acting
you know it was very hard to get the
support of my family to help me to
college to have a theatre film degree
and but what ended up happening was that
as I pursued it as I've had some
successes here and there and i showed my
parents how passionate I am about it and
they can see some of the things I've
done crazy thing that happened i didn't
expect is that they somehow actually
became supportive and now they do ask me
about how
when can I see you on TV and so I think
you do have the ability if you have that
passion that's wrong is that you can
change the way your family
you